uh i was reading i think i was reading a
lawsuit and they said that uh one of the
points brought up
is that mayor de blasio says look we've
got all these hot spots all these
red zones we got to shut them down and
then someone brought up yeah but out of
all of the red zones the only ones who
shut down were the jewish neighborhoods
right it's kind of awesome the idiot
uh gave testing in our neighborhood and
i have it on video first they came in
they do all the news conferences in city
hall
all of a sudden one day they showed up
in my neighborhood in a park
and they did it right before jewish
hollywood where everybody's cooking and
cleaning and running around with their
children getting their houses ready
they came to do a press conference right
before the holiday of course i caught
them
and i wouldn't let that idiot mitch katz
talk i just for 19 minutes screamed and
hollered and told him
how do you show up here with no
paperwork talking blindly i mean
i barely i when i do my work during the
day i need 20 pieces of documents i need
to
do research so much going on and this
guy walks and starts quoting numbers
that are impossible
and i for 90 minutes i kept screaming
and hollering at me and he left and they
got upset with me and the may of course
sent a message to his liaison we're
going to get you i said be my guest i
live at 43 16 17 avenue hello world
come on over come down that's how they
found me by the way they none of my
police officers wanted to arrest me so
they had to send
two warrant officers from the bronx wait
a minute four detectives seven cop cars
el chapo didn't have so many people
i am the man then they locked me in my
handcuffs for four hours they wouldn't
take me to the precinct they took me
straight to central booking left me in a
car four hours handcuffed making me
suffer
until i finally said you know what i'm
gonna take a leak right here in the car
am i allowed to say that
yeah okay so then where are you you you
pissed in the cop
i was going to do you rejoice i have no
problem they took me inside
and then when i got into the jail cells
everybody wanted me into their jail cell
they actually lost my fingerprints twice
do you believe this
i missed the night judge and they kept
me there for 24 hours listen to me man
i've slept in my car sleeping on a dirty
and there's no social distancing in the
police in the in the in the jails
no masks guys are there for three days
without showers dirty filthy
i'm helping a few of them now that i met
there i'm telling you so he doesn't keep
his own rules on social distance
of course we're going to have diseases
passed over there these people are
incompetent
losers so i asked him i said make me
deputy mayor i'll work with the city
i'll show you what i can do in three
weeks give me a shot
but no we're going to keep the school so
then he started closing all the school
yards
finally i had a fight with that we got
our schoolyards open some of them
because some of the superintendents
listened to me
but this guy is just foolish and then i
told my store owners no no
keep them open just for your knowledge
right before i was arrested
i was asked to join a 40 zoom conference
call i'm just a regular guy community
activist fighting for my community
they had cops on there local activists
leaders rabbis
uh politicians and they all agreed that
for the last jewish holiday which was
simchas torah which
after my two protests they asked me
don't do another protest
we want to keep the community calm
because there was a fight whatever with
me and i was being
taunting the mayor and the governor
heshi chill and so they put me on this
earth and the commission of the police
was on the
conference call and they all our leaders
said you know what for the holiday we're
going to keep our synagogues closed
and each one kept saying we're parrots
and knocking their communities
we have different communities this far
the community the syrian community
different communities different leaders
and you know i have my own imam i tell
you that i have my own pastor because i
have
muslim girl that came through my house i
have no problem i i work with all
different communities i am
a man that believes that this is a great
country my father was in the holocaust
survived it
came through fires of hell you're
telling me that i'm not gonna continue
fighting for this great country
i was born here bred here fought my way
all the way back
no no nobody's taking nothing for me and
i'm not bragging here i'm nobody special
but
i was on the phone and they're all
agreeing to this and i was one of the
last speakers
and the commissioner says well we're
gonna not enforce the rule and i told
the commissioner
right there i got on the phone i said
you're cool we have a court order
telling you that you can't do what
you're doing
the executive order he just made mr
cuomo is trying to override a court
order
he can't do this so here's the deal you
have no right to enforce it
if you do we're not going to listen to
you so if you come in your guns with
your synagogues we're not going to let
you in
you need a warrant and and the
commissioner says you can't talk to me
like that i said sure i can't i'm
telling you now
that you will not come into my
neighborhood on the holidays
wow and every synagogue was open in my
community
every place was every play group was
open okay our stores were closed anyways
due to the holiday we went out we kept
driving around
and i was driving around and the police
were very good about it our local cops
know us they love us they work with us
but again when your hierarchy wants to
boss you around they do it
my boys told me they didn't want to
arrest me that's why you had to send
people from other
districts i was going to resist i was
going to fight the cops i'm a big guy
so they beat me up by a little bloody
would have been good for the campaign
you know what i mean a little blood look
what the guy did
but the end i decided you know what i'm
going to be a man i'm going to take it
in but you know
i wasn't going to let them push me
around i walked myself around and i was
going to turn myself in anyways
that was the funny part the next morning
i was going to turn myself in but the
mayor just couldn't take it
that i was getting so much uh a
publicity
my children out there i want you to hear
me okay this is america
you are free you are free i am
free we the people i'm not gonna preach
to you the constitution or anything
you're not taking my rights you're not
coming into my home you're not locking
my doors
i don't want to take a vaccine i won't
take it yeah take it i'm not telling you
not to wear a mask when you're going to
a store
you want to go into somebody's store he
tells you to wear a mask wear mask
that's it it's your right walk on the
street leave me alone and and and the
numbers are out there
you don't have to wear a mask outside
you know the trains people are touching
everything
you can't keep it that clean we have the
restaurants open you know these outside
restaurants in new york
they're nicer than the indoor
restaurants yeah they call it uh eating
out
eating outside where you can eat inside
so long as the inside is outside of the
original inside it's meaningless this
guy's whacked and i and i've kept
restaurants open and i'm telling him to
fight but
he's shutting my people down he's
putting people out of business
and i'm fighting them back and he's
giving us fines and he's just for your
knowledge
he has health department inspectors
doing building inspections
building inspectors and parole officers
doing health inspections these guys are
not qualified he takes people with no
badges
or people with guns listen to this tim
people with gun sheriffs because our
police won't do it
climbing into little girl schools with
guns climbing through the window or
taking pictures peeping into windows
are you crazy really mr mayor you but
let me tell you what is that cop
crazy it's like he's he's crazy it's
sheriff crazy not my cops cops and all
these things but i want you to know what
happened over the weekend i would i want
you to enjoy this
uh 17 shootings four murders
i don't want to tell you that i even had
a rape last sunday thank god
we came back in my building because they
they see the buildings really empty just
that sunday me and my partner were there
thank god we saw in the camera we ran
out they tried to rape a young muslim
girl 14 year old
we stopped it we chased it we gave the
cops pictures
two days later we caught the guy because
we know our neighborhood
this is what he allows my neighbor is
patrolled nothing is boarded up downtown
brooklyn 10 minutes away from me
this is the fancy rich people i'm not
talking uh a co-op there a one-bedroom
studio can go for a million dollars
and that's cheap i'm talking that's for
the poor people
those people are boarding up their
windows they're breaking into banks
they're ripping off teller machines
because they can't be watched and this
guy is letting him get away with it but
you know what he's busy with
that we have to close our stores close
our schools and wear masks and come
after the jews
because we're quiet we're wussies well
you know what no more
my movement has started it spread it
spread around my city
it's spread to other cities like buffalo
it's spreading upstate
we're standing up even the sheriff's
upstate are you crazy you're going to
enforce thanksgiving i can only have 10
people
would you like to know how many people i
had thanksgiving in my house yeah how
many
50. i had two extra seats for cuomo and
de blasio
just in case they needed a meal i'm just
telling you and hanukkah is coming
i'm trying to get a hundred people in
there just for your knowledge
ten people youtube youtube's gone crazy
i guess i'm not getting elected
so so heshitisla.com everybody i need 25
donations from all your people i
guarantee to be what do you do with the
money
so let me tell you what i'm doing i
don't need a salary man i don't need
matching funds
i want to win with no questions asked
i'm not going in with 700 800 signatures
i'm going in there with 10 000. there
will be no doubt
i will go in there i'm going in there
with five new councilmen that i know
that are going to work with me
i have one that's going to be incumbent
from my neighborhood i have three
republicans that are worthless in
brooklyn in new york city everybody has
to run as a democrat i know people
you're upset i'm running as a democrat
well my most of my people go blind
i could be republican but i have to run
on the democratic ticket or i won't get
nothing done
so i want to go in there i want to win
i'm going to go there and and campaign
to my local community put out the
posters
i'm going to have to do a lot of stuff i
need pollsters i need people getting
signatures from me i need people running
from door to door for me i need the
office staff
elections cost money to run and i need
250 grand to run it but i'm gonna i'm
trying to raise the money and i don't
need a lot of money from people i need
twenty five fifty dollars from you guys
it in tashitishla.com you know why
because i'm going to tell you i'm going
to make a change and if it starts here
it's going to start everywhere and when
i get rid of this mayor and when i
change my city council it's called a
clean sweep
i know i've been doing it from the
outside for all these years it's time
for me to pick up
shut up or s or or stand up and i'm
going to stand up
if something doesn't change in new york
that city is going to be destroyed
completely destroyed now my son
you're just right now well slow down
fifth avenue
it's a shame you have windows that are
boarded up you can't look in macy's had
to board up their windows
restaurants are out of business i've i
have i have
people that can't pay their rent but we
raised our taxes that if you pay your
taxes rate is an 18
penalty do you believe it i can't
collect rent i can't pay rent
but if i don't pay my taxes on time i
have to pay an 18 fine
that's what they do just by the way all
fines in the city of new york have just
tripled
and tripled yeah from uh from a thousand
dollars to three thousand from five
thousand
fifty again i don't even know how that
law passed he was just able to do
without permission
and and and i want you to tell you the
best part we now have a new rule in new
york city we're allowed to rat on you
that means if
you're driving down the block tim and
you double park and i see you double
parked i take a picture of your car
you now get instead of 115 ticket 175
ticket i send it over to the city and i
get 25
i don't need to work oh yeah tim you and
me let's just drive down they're gonna
pay you
to snitch on your neighbors so you don't
believe me about this new law i'm sure
you don't believe me
so we have something that passed
recently called the idling law
that tim when you drive your car and you
pull over and you stop and you're
waiting for me to come out of the store
if you idle for more than three minutes
and i videotape you thousand dollar fine
whoa yeah and it's amazing in fact
matter of fact billy idol gets on
tv i don't know if you like him but i
don't like him anymore
i used to like him as a kid he gets on
he says don't
listen to the idling law come on man
he's making 311 was there to help the
community to
to call to see if there was complaints
on the streets now 3-1-1 is made
just to call on your neighbor they come
down the complaint doesn't exist
but the inspector always finds something
i know this is what i do for a living
i fight to inspectors i help people get
their houses back
he just comes in they find something
else to punish you
shut down your job and don't think some
of these inspectors
the prejudice as well i work with them i
take off my yamaka when i work down i'm
embarrassed to tell you that i can't
tell them i'm a jew
even though they figured it out by now
but some of them don't understand it and
i
and i just have to listen to their
prejudice their filth when they make fun
of the muslims or the asians or the
or the jewish or the black people they
themselves do it and i stand there and i
take it why
because i have to defend my people
whatever it takes for my people to win
and yes my de blasio hates us i think i
have to i have to correct you on
something
you said that they were incompetent well
hold on
uh i would say first you are partly
correct
but when you say that everything they're
doing is due to incompetence
i think they're doing that i think it's
on purpose when when we know there are
more red zones than just the jewish
parks but they go after the jewish parks
when you're you're telling me that
they're now incentivizing people to take
photos and snitch on their neighbors
they're shutting down the businesses in
defiance of the science and defiance of
the
the world health organization straight
up said last resort don't do it if you
can avoid it
they're like nah we're gonna do it
anyway cdc said don't shut down the
schools he went
i'm gonna do it anyway they're doing it
on purpose and everything they're doing
has the impact of
destroying the economy of new york city
they're burning it to the ground wow
that but you want to go a step further
not did i understand it at all
but when i did the 2000 tests in my
community and we did it in a safe clean
environment
we went to the governor mayor look we
did the right tests the 24-hour tests
and what happened yellow zone but my
neighborhood the next door neighborhood
that somehow the city you know they get
they get money for
everybody who does testing these private
organizations there's always somebody
making money on it
200 300 400 how do you do tests on the
street which i have no idea
again the neighborhood next to us red
which if you would have listened to me i
would have shown you how to do the
testing
i told you the story about the lady in
the hospital she had a baby
they wouldn't let her out she said chad
covert i came walking in there with
testing
and i showed them they're lying and on
saturday on the sabbath we picked up and
we left with the baby
no no you're not stopping us look you
lied i had one lady that was
went for operation wanted to see her
child's wedding three days later they
gave her a cover test
positive she called me up i said come on
guys really
how is she positive she's in the
hospital she's all better she's positive
i said let's give her a 24-hour test
since these pcr tests are wrong anyways
he says no okay finally after a big
fight we gave her the 24-hour test three
hours later
no no three hours later he came back is
it positive i said how can you give me a
24-hour test three hours later
i went in with my people we did the
testing we released
my city is lost i you want me to give
you an answer on corruption you want me
to tell you that
the election was fraudulent there's
something wrong here
and and and the people in the in in the
hierarchy think that they own us
stop it i'm not gonna let them own me
i'm gonna fight back
my my community is fighting back we're
standing up a lot of them are scared to
lose the big bucks
i know i know it's a shame especially
for special needs children
i know for the welfare i know for the
meals on wheels i know we have a lot of
programs out there
but you know what the jewish community
got 20 000 last year for postpartum
depression
it's a very bad issue in my community
the neighborhood over that's not jewish
got 43 million dollars
we have a 90 billion dollar budget
that's 9 billion dollars in the hole
now normally when you're in the hole
you've got to lay off some of your
workers
so he laid off the whole new york city
right none of us are allowed to go to
work
all 337 000 employees of new york city
were working throughout the entire
covert
300 all you had to do was lay off maybe
about one quarter of them
to save on your budget never did it why
because something is wrong here he keeps
collecting he keeps finding so he made
up for the tourism problem
because he only gets like eight or ten
percent of that to with the fines
that's what he did the man is an
incompetent doesn't know how to run the
city i am a competency i
i gotta tell you it sounds like i
believe he's incompetent
but come on that's on purpose huh he
found a way because our house we took
our community that was
it fires you know the bronx in the 70s
was all burnt down
brooklyn also was in the in the late
1800s
under siege and we have built fought
brick by brick house by house fought
legalized went through every attorney
general found every law to rebuild a
community we have 200
000 people you know how many drug
centers we have one two youth centers
we have drug problems we have kids in
with issues again they won't give us the
money for it so we have to do it
ourselves
the man only cares about himself i'm
sorry no no no no you're uh you're
running as a democrat
but i remember seeing these protests and
i remember seeing a bunch of people
carrying big old trump flags
we love mystery president again
his policies are correct he's done a
great job with the economy
i am a man for trump again in new york
city we have a problem
we are a blue state there's nothing to
question people
i saw it but you know i went i when my
my mother passed away three years ago
and uh people came to my house to to you
know while i was mourning because i go
to
all the homes i go visit a lot of people
and i had hundreds of people come to say
it was so nice of them
that's why i l i love my community and
and they were just good to me and where
i raised my children they all came to
wish me well
and people said these two guys are
running for councilman who are
incompetent one cheated to get in again
he was able to get himself on the ballot
by cheating
and he got the democratic nobody knew
this guy
and the next guy got an independent and
i with three weeks to go with fifteen
thousand dollars i ran
as an independent now i won them in the
debate i was great
but the point is people went to the
polls blindly and just clicked democrat
democrat democrat the guy
won and the last four years i don't want
to knock him he's i like him don't get
me wrong he's a nice boy
again nothing has been done hasn't stood
up when i started cutting the locks of
the parks they showed up
hi ashley we're here to help you where
are you one day and then they disappear
again
they're hiding in their basements
they're passing laws legislation
crying about budgets which they've never
done a budget before in their life you
know i didn't take any ppe money
when my when we were doing covert i kept
every one of my workers working
home running around because we were a
lot of my people were essential
and i kept working them and were paying
him and trust me it hurt us because we
tried to have a cushion in the business
we work on it we're worried for busy
days my wife and me know that bad days
are coming
and we've used it mr may de blasio is
spoiled he has no idea so when i keep
saying incompetent
forget that what he's after to get us of
course a bigot
wants to come after the easy prey of
course he wants to go after
the poor black family that can't stand
up for themselves and then there's a lot
of black people that could stand up and
take advantage of the situation
we have the same thing in the jewish
community you know we have guys buying
up
poor people's houses and then after he
buys up the whole community says oh
let's move to jersey let's all go to
israel
no no i'm here i'm here to stay i don't
care what you've abused us
there's always somebody in every
community it sounds like the jails too
are getting abused
people are getting stuffed in a cell
with no proper you know
i go through this i go to jail every two
weeks to visit people and i
see the the the the way they
abuse them and you're right some of you
gonna say well they deserve it they
don't deserve it
you know i have people coming home from
i'm into prison reform and people come
home
you think they can be better in one day
they've served seven years three years
nine months in jail
people lose focus i'm there to try to
help them to guide them i'm not their
boss don't get it out of their way i'm
not i know they're gonna cause some
issues
i'm there to help them if they want help
so in response to
stories about the jails being
overcrowded people getting sick they
started just cutting people loose
and then we started seeing a bunch of
people getting cut loose committing
crimes yeah so that was a that was a big
complaint from conservatives
i should say and many of them didn't
live in new york but they were pointing
to new york saying how insane is it
that you're going to let these people go
but then my position is like first of
all
if somebody isn't convicted and they're
in jail because they just
got charged they may be innocent then i
don't think we can stuff them into
you know a disease-written
shoulder-to-shoulder you know cell so
what do you do do you do you know so the
new york
uh passed that bail reform law right
correct cashless bail
but there's so much that we could do
there's so many ideas
on uh wearing uh um a device on your leg
um having people it's not just bail
having people take responsibility for
you
i'm not asking for bail the parole
officers are busy watching our stores
and giving us violations
when they should be watching these guys
who were letting out on bail
or nobel you know they were even
considering and giving me bail
for a riot it never happened by the way
my riot never happened
this guy i don't want not to talk really
about it my lawyers are going to kill me
not that i care because i never listen
to lawyers lawyers all stupid god
yeah we need them they are guys i'm more
smarter than them
but always never trust your lawyer
listen to me guys
you are the boss you watch them yeah
they know the law they know the
paperwork you do your research today
with the internet you can do it
be your own boss they are your employee
some of these lawyers again think
they're smarter than you i don't care
what they charge
so i know this guy woke me up at three
o'clock in the morning i was pissed
and he came to he came to the first
protest and the second protest wasn't
set up by me
the cops themselves called me in middle
of the night said heshi
the kids are burning masks masks we
didn't make no big fights it was put out
with a fire extinguisher
has she come help us i said but i'm home
in bed my wife is gonna kill me
get over here as she so i got out of bed
i came there i broke up the protest
and i told everybody go home and nobody
wanted to go so the cop said if you
all go home we'll allow you to come back
tomorrow for two hours with music
and you can have like a dancing holiday
protest and i got on the microphone the
police microphone
and i told everybody and everybody went
home the next day this guy who was at
the first protest
again he woke me up in the middle of the
night telling me you're a bad man called
me some bad name and i went over to him
in the street like i would see you tim
if you went and started you know waking
me up a little night come over you tim
you're a bad man you're crazy and of
course whenever there's a fight a lot of
people came around and just saw my
little
argument and the cops were all stationed
i had them stationed beautifully all
around the two black area
two minutes later they came and whisked
him off his brother-in-law was there
protecting him
nothing happened what did i do threat
entrapment and
signing a riot why do i nobody was
arrested that night
nothing was burned down no windows were
broken nothing happened you mean
incitement
right entitlement rights nobody was
arrested even the cops are laughing that
nothing happened
nobody was arrested and all of a sudden
they come three days later after i talk
to the police commissioner they come and
ask me
why they may de blasio wanted to show
that he's the boss you know what he's
not the boss
i'm my own boss people your own boss
stand up
don't be scared if you're scared come to
a guy come to an activist
i am not scared i fight for you know my
father told me something i'm sure you
heard this
before he passed away i was a little boy
and he told me he says has she there's
two things in life you can do that's it
that's all he told me
you can do something or you can do
nothing that's it
that's your whole that's my philosophy
i'm never gonna do nothing my sons
i'm never gonna do it i'm always gonna
be there to do something i'm always
gonna be to the
rest of my life as much as to my last
dying breath i know some of you guys
believe in god
you don't believe in god when i stand
before the holy maker
i'm going to give him an answer i'm
going to tell him what i did i screwed
up
don't get me wrong me and linda fight
every day she's usually wrong
but i don't laugh at him she is
i love you baby you're so gorgeous 31
years she's tortured me
i love the way anyways i want you to
know this is what we do
it's a battle each day and my woman is
with me and i'm so proud of her for
allowing me
to stand up even though we discussed me
and linda discussed this was the year
that i was gonna retire we were gonna we
put away a little bit of money we were
gonna go into the sun and flowers i was
gonna watch my tv on the beach all day
long and make fun of all you people but
it came up that we can't
we can't let our children our
grandchildren our foster children you
know some of these foster children we
had you know
i was a little tough on you know i'm a
big fat guy so i threatened to put them
in the basement naked you know
it's a joke it's a joke stop it i'm
laughing i know yeah
look at it he has something in his hands
he's going to throw it at me
i was a little tough linda was always
good loving mother and you know what
they call it to this day and something's
i
i'm so proud when they call her and they
speak to her
and i laugh behind the scenes how hard
we worked on that and
and linda giggles even though of all
those you know terrible days that we had
with them
i'm proud of her and i'm proud that
she's my woman and she stood by me
you know you've got to be there
everybody's got their quirks everybody's
got their
their crazy uh you know sicknesses in
them again like drugs i'm against drugs
i don't care about marijuana being
approved i don't care what your audience
says because i know little kids have it
i've been against drugs
all my life there are ways that you can
do it in your home not for me
never for me i'm here to fight for my
children i'm here to fight for the next
generation i'm here to fight for my
neighbor i'm here to fight for my senior
citizens
this is what i do from morning to late
at night
and never will i stop trust me never
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you